le chu de besançon pour faire un second
point sur les coronavirus dans notre
région savait que le directeur général
de l'agencé avait fait un premier point
vendredi dernier dijon nous étions à
l'époque en phase 1
désormais nous sommes ce qu'on appelle
en phase 2 de l'épidémie et donc nous
refaisons un point avec vous aujourd'hui
je vous propose que l'on commence par
dérouler l'actualité de la semaine sur
le sujet et ensuite évidemment nous
répondrons à toutes les questions que
vous pourriez avoir sur le sujet alors
en ce qui concerne le déroulé de nos
trains de notre propos introductif donc
je vais premier point sur la situation
du coronavirus sur braye franche comté
puis un peu plus spécifiquement dans la
partie franc comtoise de la région avant
de passer la parole au chu de besançon
et que sa directrice générale et le
docteur blasco pour vous donner un peu
plus d'éléments sur la façon de
médicalement
les patients sont sont prises en charge
à partir du moment où ils sont
diagnostiqués et les
vous préfet de département du doubs et
du territoire de belfort importeront
quelques compléments sur les
implications pour notre vie quotidienne
à tous que peu à voir l'épidémie
actuellement et ensuite nous répondrons
à toutes vos questions
donc en ce qui concerne le point donc de
situation vous avez je pense vous êtes
aussi bien informés que nous puisque
vous savez qu'un point quotidien est
fait par le niveau national que vous
avez toutes les informations sur le site
national info coronavirus pour autant la
situation donc et rapidement évolutive
de jour en jour ça si vous a pas échappé
et la bourgogne franche comté n'est pas
original dans ce cadre là puisque nous
avons eu une augmentation rapide du
nombre des cas depuis une semaine avec
les quatre premiers cas donc la semaine
dernière jeudi dernier à dijon est
désormais le point de situation qui a
été fait hier le dernier communiqué de
presse que nous avait eu donc faisait
état de 44 cas dans la région bourgogne
franche comté de cas confirmés sachant
que la situation est effectivement
rapidement évolutive puisque depuis le
point de situation hier à 16 heures
nous avons de nouveau
24 cas supplémentaires depuis depuis
donc cette situation rapidement
évolutive mérite de s'attarder un
instant sur à partir des 44 cas qui sont
documentés à ce jour puisqu'elle encore
une fois le mécanisme et continue je
vais y revenir un petit peu ensuite sur
la façon dont le processus se déroule
les malades aujourd'hui sont bons c'est
cette quarantaine de cas qui sont
aujourd'hui avérés documenté suivi
depuis donc le point d'hier deux sont
aujourd'hui guéri je pense qu'il faut
quand même se rappeler qu'il s'agit
d'une maladie virale de type d'épisodes
grippale est donc bien évidemment les
patients après avoir été confiné isolé
guéri ses ressorts nous avons les deux
premiers patients qui étaient
hospitalisées à dijon qui sont ressortis
l'hospitalisation guéri sur ces
quarantaine de patients aujourd'hui 16
sont hospitalisées dont deux en
réanimation 1 dijon 1 besançon et 24
d'entre eux sont à domicile
je pense que ça c'est une information
importante puisque depuis cette semaine
comme vous le savez à partir du moment
où les patients en situation clinique
médicale stable et n'inspire pas
d'inquiétude
ils peuvent être maintenus à domicile
évidemment confiné à domicile mais suivi
à distance et donc ne pas être
systématiquement hospitalisés donc à ce
jour dans c'est déjà plus de la moitié
des patients ne confirme et sont
maintenus à domicile donc sont malades à
domicile et par chance nous n'avons
encore à ce jour à déplorer aucun décès
dans la région bord et franche comté
les patients hospitalisés sont
aujourd'hui dans fait hospitaliser dans
quatre établissements
il y a dix établissements prêt à les
recevoir dans la région comme vous le
savez aussi ça c'est une donnée que vous
aviez déjà la semaine dernière avec les
deux chu bien sûr comme établissement
pivot de référence et huit
établissements qui sont armés pour
prendre en charge les patients confirmés
et donc aujourd'hui deux d'entre eux le
l'hôpital nord franche-comté d'une tare
mais le centre hospitalier de mâcon
d'autre part ont tous les deux des
patients hospitalisés
en leur sein donc cette cette évolution
dont comme je voulais 10 et rapide et
évidemment elle est liée à un certain
nombre de transmissions de chaînes de
transmission épidémiologique qui fait
que la région franche comté est montée
brutalement dans le train de l'épidémie
cette semaine avec le je dirais une
chaîne de transmission qui a été
documentée à partir notamment nous avons
deux chaînes de transmission dans la
région qui sont prouvés afin qu'ils sont
documentés l'une en provenance de l'oise
l'autre en provenance du rassemblement
évangélique dont qui a lu à mulhouse
dans la dernière semaine de février et à
partir desquels donc les cas sont
l'essentiel aujourd'hui de
décontamination de la partie franc
comtoise de la région puisque
actuellement sur nos 42 4 k nous en
avons que d'une trentaine qui sont
directement liés à cette transmission de
l'événement de mulhouse donc l'actualité
évidemment donc évolué d'heure en heure
nous avons actuellement ce jour est
également quelques cas dans les ehpad et
notamment un ehpad de la région qui a
plusieurs cas groupés mais encore une
fois sans hospitalisation les personnes
résidentes de cet établissement sont
toutes relativement bien et sont
évidemment isolés dans leur et padmé
sont maintenus dans l'ordre dans leur
établissement
donc là la phase 2 de l'épidémie si vous
reprend juste très rapidement je vous
rappelle que la phase 1 c'était éviter
l'introduction dû virus
la phase 2 c'était limité sa progression
la phase iii c'est limiter les
conséquences de la diffusion massive de
l'épidémie aujourd'hui nous sommes en
phase 2
certains pensent que certaines zones
sont d'ores et déjà en limite de phase
iii et c'est vrai que là maintenant le
débat va se déplacer au niveau national
sur la je dirais la catégorisation des
zones qui seront en phase 3 puisque
comme la grippe je dirais c'est assez
analogue là encore vous savez qu'il ya
des régions qui sont en phase épidémique
d'autres qui le sont moins cent face
vert orange rouge est bien pour le coc
vite 19 ça va être la même chose il y à
des régions des départements qui ont des
clusters qui sont d'ores et déjà dans
des phases épidémique de niveau
équivalent 3 alors que d'autres régions
sont encore au niveau 1 avec très peu de
cas
donc les stratégies de prise en charge
des patients aujourd'hui son uniforme
sur l'ensemble du territoire
et c'est peut-être ça qui peut être
amené à évoluer en fonction de la
situation de chaque département
dans les semaines qui viennent ça on
pourra éventuellement répondre à vos
questions
alors le je voudrais insister sur un
point à ce stade qui est que cette phase
2 suppose donc que en dehors de
évidemment d'isolement des malades et
des précautions importants qui sont
prises pour les cas contacts et
notamment d'éviction là aussi
professionnelle pour les cas contacts il
n'y a pas de restriction autres
actuellement dans je dirais les
activités de la vie quotidienne autre
que les mesures habituelles qui sont
préconisées en cas d'épisode virale et
ce sont les mesures dites barrière je
vais pas vous les rôlistes et vous avez
tous entendu je pense à satiété dans
tous les médias entre le lavage des
mains on ne se touche pas et c'est donc
ça c'est effectivement important il faut
prendre conscience et je pense que vous
qui avez un rôle est important les
médias par rapport à l'ensemble de la
population
c'est vraiment un élément capital qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que ces mesures
barrières sont vraiment la mesure la
plus efficace de réduction de la
transmission des virus dans la
population c'est vraiment ça la mesure
efficace
à partir du moment où on fait cela on a
une vraie réduction du risque et toutes
les autres mesures évidemment seront
prises en cas de besoin en tant que de
besoin pour les malades
c'est vraiment ça la réduction j'ai
coutume de dire sur une forte de 2000
boutade canton canton tout ce qu'on a de
la fièvre on va embrasser sa grand mère
ça paraît évident quand on a la grippe
c'est encore plus vrai aujourd'hui
si on a une suspicion de coronavirus
donc pour pour terminer après je dis pas
que j'aurais des questions sur les
masques et autres joyeusetés mais sans
me répondra dans le débat je pense
important de rappeler également que en
cas de suspicion les personnes doit
vraiment ne pas se précipiter chez leur
médecin traitant ou aux urgences de
l'hôpital mais véritablement le
mécanisme a été prévu pour que
l'épidémie ne diffuse paraît donc toute
personne qui a un doute qui a côtoyé
quelqu'un qui a été malade et c'est
véritablement doit appeler le 15 pour
que le 15 lorient au mieux ça sera
peut-être effectivement de l'envoyer
chez son médecin traitant parce qu'il
n'est pas du tout dans une dans une
suspicion et donc le système normal
d'offre de soins peut jouer mais il faut
vraiment appeler le 15 et pas aller je
dirais risque qui prend des risques dans
des salles d'attentes de cabinet libéral
ou encore plus aux services d'urgence et
pour les plus inquiets
là aussi on le dit comme vous le savez
tous les jours mais je pense que
n'hésitez pas à profiter de
l'opportunité de des papiers que vous
allez écrire pour rappeler que toutes
les questions tous les gens qui peuvent
être inquiet je suis allé en mongolie
intérieure est ce que je revois mes
enfants l'écho la semaine prochaine
c'est vraiment 0,833 0 il ya vraiment le
numéro vert national qui est actif 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 et qui est
vraiment là pour ça et surtout qu'il
n'appelle pas le cas cela parce que le
15 et un système puissant et sensible et
donc il faut d'ores et déjà le quinze de
la région les quatre centres 15 de la
région ont eu une augmentation
considérable de leur activité depuis le
début du mois de février avec l'épisode
koffi 19
il faut véritablement épargnée les
ressources précieuses spécialisés qui
sont là pour orienter les patients et
pas pour rassurer les inquiets je pense
que ça c'est véritablement un message
qu'il faut aussi que l'on repasse
collectivement après vous répondre à
toutes vos questions
je vous propose de passer la parole à
même carroger sur la partie prise en
charge vue de l'hôpital mercy
alors tout d'abord je voudrais vraiment
dire combien il est important de
souligner l'engagement des
professionnels du chu de besançon dans
sa période de crise c'est important de
dire parce que nous avons des agents qui
sont sur le pont vingt-quatre heures sur
vingt-quatre et en particulier vraiment
je voulais qu mercier le professeur qui
cousent et le peuple est là aujourd'hui
parce que l'été jour depuis plus de 15
jours
elle est dans son service à prendre en
charge des situations donc vraiment
c'est trop content de le dire surtout
que vous savez on est dans une période
encore de vacances scolaires et que on a
donc du personnel en moins et donc que
le personnel présent a su faire face et
continuent à faire face beaucoup comment
merci à eux
alors on va vous dire deux choses
peut-être comment s'est organisée au
niveau du chu de besançon
sur le plan des sculptures qu'on ait mis
en classe et puis le docteur d'asco nous
parlera davantage de la prise en charge
des patients alors ce qu'il faut
peut-être déjà dire c'est que les chu
sont préparés à ce type d'épidémie faut
pas croire qu'on parle de zéro vous
rappelez tous de la grippe aviaire s'est
pas si vieux que ça donc à l'époque des
procédures avaient été écrits puis en
place donc il y avait déjà tout une
situation de pré existante et donc en
avait déjà des procédures pour autant
compte tenu de cette situation un peu
particulière
nous avons dès la semaine dernière mis
en place une cellule de veille pour
essayer de voir comment on allait donc
mettre en place les structures en
fonction des événements et cette cellule
de veille s'est transformé cette semaine
en cellule de crise et donc cette
cellule de crise se réunit tous les
jours donc depuis depuis sept semaines
et son objectif c'est d'adapter
l'organisation des soins pour assurer la
continuité des soins en fonction de la
connaissance que nous avons du sujet au
jour le jour
alors que qu'avons nous fait je pense
qu'il faut d'abord dire que voilà en
l'absence de visibilité sur l'évolution
du virus et compte tenu de
l'augmentation du nombre de cas parce
que c'est clair que le nombre de cas
augmente depuis 48 heures en se
mobiliser on appris très vite des
mesures qui sont déjà opérationnels et
qui seront opérationnels ce week-end
première mesure
un centre 15 nous avons augmenté le
nombre de postes téléphoniques
nous avons aujourd'hui au centre de
régulation régionale sans que quinze 15
fausses nous sommes passés en début de
semaine à trois postes supplémentaires
et nous avons réquisitionné cette
semaine une salle la salle de
restauration des internes pour la
transformer en salle de régulation avec
quinze postes supplémentaires et à
partir donc de ce week-end nous aurons
quinze postes supplémentaires avec des
personnels médicaux informés qu'ils vont
pouvoir prendre en charge les appels
téléphoniques on voit bien que les
appels téléphoniques augmente on en a
plus de 200 par jour en plus de ce qu'on
reçoit d'habitude et ça va augmenter
puisque plus on va déclarer de cas plus
je pense que les les personnes vont se
manifester dans premières mesures
nous avons créé deux salles de
débordements qui sur qui sont
opérationnels et qui permettent de
répondre aux nombreux appels quotidiens
ensuite ce que nous avons fait et qui
est opérationnel dès demain nous avons
créé une salle d'accueil spécifique au
niveau des urgences de manière à ce que
des patients qui arrivent avec peut-être
ou pas le syndrome covit 19 ne rentre
pas dans les urgences pour ne pas
polluer entre guillemets les patients
qui seraient présentons que nous avons
mis en place une salle qu'on appelle
salle d'accueil spécifique qui sera donc
pour les personnes qui ont des
insuffisances respiratoires qui ont des
problèmes respiratoires qui seront tout
de suite dirigé donc sur cette unité et
qui seront soit transporté par les
pompiers
soit qu'ils auront été expertisé
précédemment et donc qui arriveront et
qui seront bilan t en fonction de l'état
de santé pourront aller son organisation
soient en service de médecine
infectieuse ou pas si c'est un syndrome
respiratoire
mais si c'est pas le kobe de 19 alors
nous avons pris hier soir et donc on
vole annonce aujourd'hui nous avons pris
la cellule de crise a pris hier soir la
décision de déprogrammer une partie de
la chirurgie alors pourquoi parce que
nous avons besoin de personnel
et vous le savez aussi certainement
parmi les personnes qui aujourd'hui sont
cons sont positifs nous avons des agents
de l'hôpital
donc nous avons des absences liées au
fait que nous avons des agents malades
et malheureusement c'est des agents qui
sont dans les salles plus dans les
services de médecine chirurgie voilà
c'est le hasard qui a fait que c'est
plus des agents de médecine
donc il faut que nous renforcions des
services de médecine en personnel pour
cela il faut qu'on on on essaye d'avoir
moins de lits de chirurgie pour pouvoir
mettre à disposition des personnels en
particulier des des infirmes et de
réanimation qui vont pouvoir conforter
les services de réanimation des
infirmiers qui vont être formés de
manière à pouvoir renforcer les services
de médecine infectieuse puisque on a
augmenté la capacité de lits de service
de médecine infectieuse
alors qu'est ce que nous avons décidé de
déprogrammer nous avons décidé de
déprogrammer les passions qui devait
venir pour une prise en charge un peu
lourde qui supposait de
l'hospitalisation mais qui n'est pas
urgent qu bien évidemment toutes les
urgences
tous les cas qui ne peuvent pas attendre
seront pris en charge normalement et
dans toutes les conditions de sécurité
seront prises en charge au chu
nous ne déprogrammerons pas l'activité
ambulatoire
donc attention toutes les personnes qui
sont prévues de venir en ambulatoire et
vous le savez c'est les patients qui
arrivent le matin sont opérés dans la
journée pourquoi par ce soir ne sont pas
des programmes et parce qu'en fait ces
gens-là n'utilise pas de lit et donc du
coup ça ne nous dégage pas entre
guillemets du personnel on dégage des
lits pour dégager du personnel pour
pouvoir en plus de personnel selon les
services de médecine
donc pour vous donner à peu près un
ordre d'idée sur 324 interventions qui
sont programmées la semaine prochaine à
peu près 300 24 70 seront déprogrammés
et bien entendu les patients dès
aujourd'hui puisque cette décision a été
prise hier à 20h
donc dès aujourd'hui les patients seront
prévenus que leur opération les 70 mais
pas les autres surtout neuneu ne dit pas
qu'on ferme les services de chirurgie
parce que c'est pas du tout la situation
on prévoit cette mesure pour les 15
prochains jours et puis à 8 jours on
réévaluera s'il faut plus ou moins on ne
sait pas ce qui va se passer on ne sait
pas combien on va voir car donc on
préfère être prudent et anticipe et
peut-être que finalement on a pris une
mesure qui n'était peut-être pas utile
mais comme on ne sait pas on peut pas
déprogrammé aussi facilement on claque
pas des doigts on ne programme pas parce
que derrière il ya toute une
organisation il a toute une logistique
donc on préfère être prudent on a pris
cette décision hier avec l'équipe
médicale pour qu'un jour on va voir
peut-être que on est trop précautionneux
mais il ne faut pas qu'on se mette en
insécurité
il ne faut pas mettre en insécurité
notre personnel donc on s'organise pour
avoir du personnel
là où il faut au moment il faut dans nos
services ensuite donc heureusement en
attend lundi parce que les effectifs
vont revenir puisque on a encore des
gens en congé donc c'est toujours
compliqué de faire revenir les
personnels mais donc on aura un peu plus
de personnel on a demandé aussi de
l'aide notamment pour le centre 15 des
des collègues du département et même de
la région puisqu'on a demandé aux
collègues urgentistes de dole pour venir
nous aider les réactions sont très
positives
on a fait appel aussi à la croix rouge
qui a répondu présent tout de suite et
j'en profite pour les remercier
devant vous parce que il n'ya pas de
souci tout de suite les
et nous avons su une réponse positive
voilà on a demandé aussi au service de
soins de suite et de réadaptation du du
bassin de besançon de nous prendre des
patients pour pouvoir libérer des lits
ce que je vous dis notre souci c'est de
libérer des lits est pareil aussi
réactions positives et ils s'organisent
pour nous prendre des patients voilà
donc ce que je veux vraiment je voudrais
vous dire c'est que la situation était
maîtrisée
on sait ce qu'on fait on sait ce qu'on
doit faire on sait ce qu'on va faire
l'équipe est sur le pont on est à peu
près 25 tous les jours autour de la
table avec des urgentistes avec les
médecins de médecine infectieuse avec
l'équipe d'hygiène avec les chefs de
pôle avec toutes les personnes qui
aujourd'hui sont en fait pas si tu es
autour de moi et du président de la cme
dupont dans sa mémoire de de prendre les
meilleures décisions
voilà et nous ne sommes pas honnêtement
franchement on n'est pas inquiet on
s'organise et c'est normal de
s'organiser
peut-être le jour où on nous dira
prendre la tête c'est un peu trop mais
je pense qu'il vaut mieux agir comme ça
prévenir et on évaluera alors sur les
circuits la prise en charge des patients
le docteur blasco qui donc le remplace
le professeur surprise merci madame la
directrice
donc comme l'a dit madame la directrice
tout doit passer par le centre 15 on
martèle encore un petit peu mais je
franchement c'est important mes
collègues ce matin du centre 15
mon monde demandait encore de repréciser
et de prendre votre relais les gens
appellent le centre casse on appelle le
centre 15 il ya une évaluation qui est
fait par un médecin
la directrice l'a dit ce médecin donc en
fonction des critères définis
je vous passe les protocoles ou autre ce
serait trop long mais dit oui vous êtes
un cas possible de covile 19 le patient
est adressée alors soit il est
symptomatique
il va aller directement en
maladie alors soit symptomatique sévère
et on vous l'a dit on a ouvert un centre
d'accueil des problèmes respiratoires
indépendamment des urgences et là il va
y avoir donc comme l'a dit madame la
directrice
une évaluation du nation et ce patient
donc pourrait regagner à partir de là là
comment dirais-je le service de maladies
infectieuses qui est vraiment notre là
où il ya les experts et là où on a le
tout ce qu'il faut et enfin de
connaissances et tout ce qu'il faut pour
prendre en charge ce type de passer la
deuxième chose on n'est pas
symptomatique du mont pas réellement
mais on a des cas où on a été en contact
et on présente des signes de la fièvre
en fait tout ce qui vous avait relayé
jusqu'à maintenant de la fièvre de la
toux et par exemple en contact un retour
b2b de mulhouse ont parlé de mulhouse et
c'est pourquoi pas je prends un exemple
précis vous êtes dans cet état eh bien
on va pouvoir vous recevoir aussi à ceux
dans le service de maladies infectieuses
vous investir vous investiguer radio
pulmonaire examen qu'il discutait
prélèvements pour l'instant donc on fait
des prélèvements ces prélèvements sont
analysés dans un laboratoire spécialisé
de virologie au chu
pendant ce temps là donc on reste à
l'hôpital
on a globalement trois quatre heures
d'attentes pour avoir le résultat le
patient et bien sûr isolé dans un box
dédiée à ménager les soignants sont
briefés sur les mesures à prendre les
mesures de protection et donc à partir
de là le patient et de cette évaluation
et du résultat est bien le patient est
soit hospitalisé en maladies
infectieuses soit regagner son domicile
voilà un petit peu le
le schéma général vous voyez que tout
passe par le centre 15 qui est vraiment
vraiment le lieu où on peut avoir une
aucune expertise téléphonique faire
venir ou pas le patient ont décidé d'eux
si le centre 15 est en difficulté ça
peut arriver parce que en médecine
tout n'est pas toujours si simple tous
les protocoles et les flèches ne
correspondent pas à ce moment là il ya
eu même bien sûr c'est au cas par cas
c'est du sur mesure et il ya une
évaluation bien sûr qu'ils aient pris
avec l'équipe d'infectiologie de madame
chez rose pour dire oui on fait venir ce
cas on évalue en effet six ans
voilà un petit peu l'organisation au
niveau du centre 15 et du service de
maladies infectieuses avec l'anc a lieu
je voulais dit d'hospitalisation
même la directrice nous a dit qu'on est
en train de structurer effectivement
pour étendre les lits de possibilités
aux spécialisations c'est tout le but
et puis un service d'évaluation qu'on
appelle non en hôpital de jour
comme je voulais dit c'est cet hôpital
entre guillemets il ya une consultation
qui ai fait le prélèvement est fait et
on en attend les résultats
une précision le circuit ambulatoire est
balisé c'est dire si vous aussi vous
verrez que il ya des panneaux qui vous
indiquent le chemin que vous devez
prendre sa double passion vallée sur un
parking live a appelé on va venir le
chercher
on va lui mettre un masque et on va le
conduire jusqu'à dans une salle qui est
vraiment à l'entrée alors pas du tout ça
c'est pas du tout à l'entrée des
urgences pas du tout en tant que
principal mais sur sur le côté où on a
mis deux salles qui permettent aux à la
personne de rentrer il à l'examen il
attend ici il attend de voir mais il va
pas se
circuler dans tout l'hôpital c'est
vraiment la première porte quand on
quand on passe sur côté et donc le
chemin est balisé les les personnes qui
sont à l'entrée de l'hôpital savent
donner les inscriptions pour pas que le
patient se taire parce que vous le savez
c'est compliqué pour ceux que les au chu
de besançon
mais c'est organisé on va le chercher
sur le parking on lui met un masque et
on l'accompagnent pour faire ce
prélèvement
ces deux circuits ambulatoire écoutez
merci de ces précisions je ne veux pas
qu'il pourrait y avoir des questions
encore de complément propose de passer
la porte parole nationale préfet du
doubs qui peut nous donner sans doute
des informations également un peu plus
générale sur la crainte qui peut
s'exprimer parfois chez nos concitoyens
par rapport à fait nommer l'épidémie qui
encore une fois ressemble beaucoup à ce
que nous connaissons tous les hivers
avec la grille merci bonjour donc vous
avez compris que le département du doubs
et est désormais concerné comme l'a
souligné me dit ah toi général adjoint
de lairesse essentiellement donc liés à
l'évènement cultuel de mulhouse pour ce
qui concerne donc les enjeux liés à
l'organisation et à la continuité des
services
nous avons mis en place une cellule de
suivi opérationnel kobe de 19 avec la
lance rignol le sentait les forces de
sécurité intérieures les gendarmes les
pompiers les policiers puis l'ensemble
des services de l'état donc concernés
pour assurer que le suivi précis donc de
la continuité des services en
particulier des services publics nous
avons également bien sûr mis en place un
suivi
pottas taux régulier avec les élus je
suis en contact avec les parlementaires
du département et avec les maires le
président de l'association des maires et
avec les maires des chefs lieux
d'arrondissement le l'enjeu c'est
d'abord d'appliquer les mesures
nationales comme vous le savez nous
sommes en stade 2 donc la règle pour ce
qui concerne la limitation des
rassemblements mais c'est la seule règle
qui s'appliquera à ce stade de notre
département c'est la limitation des
rassemblements en milieu confiné pour
des rassemblements qui en même temps
robot 5000 personnes et à ce stade c'est
la seule règle que nous appliquons dans
le département pour le reste et au cas
par cas et en lien avec les
organisateurs ou avec les autorités les
autorités municipales en fonction de la
sensibilité donc des personnes nous
pourront le cas échéant prendre des
mesures mais vraiment au cas par cas
mais la règle générale la seule règle
qui s'applique dans le département
aujourd'hui c'est celle de la limitation
des rassemblements en même temps dans un
milieu profiler pour les rassemblements
comportant plus de 5000 personnes en
même temps
c'est la seule règle nous avons mis en
place avec les acteurs du monde
économique avec la chambre de commerce
et d'industrie la chambre d'agriculture
et la chambre des métiers et de
l'artisanat
une cellule de veille économique donc
qui se comptent qui est en contact
régulier avec mon secrétaire général
pour pouvoir bien sûr là aussi apporter
des réponses au cas par cas
d'abord le suivi et puis il ya des
pensions cas par cas pour les accords
que les acteurs économiques pour les
entreprises
et comme nous avons par exemple déjà
identifié a donc des situations qui
nécessiteront un accompagnement avec le
directeur départemental des finances
publiques ou avec l'urssaf donc
les entreprises qui sont dans le domaine
de l'événementiel qui ont clairement
aujourd'hui donc les difficultés dans
l'approché de leur activité économique
cette cellule de veille
bien sûr animé et il s'agira d'apporter
des réponses concrètes précises aux
entreprises dans un objectif est clair
c'est celui de la continuité de
l'activité économique s'agit de ne pas
surréagir de prendre des décision
proportionnée et bien sûr avec une
capacité d'agilité en suivant les
recommandations sanitaires
par exemple là où ce sera nécessaire
nous accompagnerons les entreprises pour
qu'elles puissent donc le mettre en
place le télétravail un certain nombre
d'actions
mais l'enjeu c'est assurer la continuité
de l'activité économique sur notre
département
nous sommes aussi en contact b / avec
les grands donneurs d'ordre du secteur
industriel donc on pourrait évidemment
veiller à ce que la vie puisse avoir
toutes les informations opérationnelles
nécessaires pour poursuivre l'activité
l'activité économique dans un cadre bien
sûr avec des décisions km proportions
enfin pour ce qui concerne donc
globalement latitude en termes d'ordre
public que je les ai dit tout à l'heure
je insiste il n'y a aucune consigne pour
des rassemblements autre que les
rassemblements en milieu confiné à plus
de 5000 personnes
néanmoins il appartiendra à chacun à
chaque organisateur de manifestation de
pouvoir faire en sorte que les bonnes
pratiques les bons gestes ce que donc
directeur général de l'adjoint de l'air
s appelle les d'arrière les gestes
barrière puisse être appliquée
aujourd'hui donc quand on va dans un
rassemblement
quand on va dans une manifestation à 300
400 personnes 200 personnes aujourd'hui
j'ai cette manifestation ne sont pas
interdits dans le département mais il
convient évidemment là aussi d'appliquer
les gestes barrière donc on ne
s'embrasse pas on se serre pas la main
etc etc je voulais en terminant le
propos donc lancé un appel très fort sur
la protection des personnes vulnérables
et en particulier donc les personnes
donc âgé il convient vraiment que nous
puissions avoir la clairement
des attitudes très stricte dans nos
comportements
ce n'est pas le moment de rendre visite
à la grand-mère au grand père qui est à
l'ehpad
il faudra vraiment veiller à ce que les
personnes âgées puissent être donc en
situation d'être protégé par rapport par
rapport à cette situation sanitaire
voilà donc cadre dans lequel nous
travaillons je devais le souligner en
terminant mon propos en lien étroit et
avec une mobilisation exemplaire des
services blessure de la chance de le
santé mais aussi du chru et de
l'ensemble des services de l'état les
plus en proximité de défense de sécurité
intérieure les pompiers je préfère merci
et peut-être l'état d'esprit
l'organisation sont similaires quelques
quelques éléments donnés en moi bon je
relaie comme tout le monde l'appelle à
la responsabilité individuelle se
propres se protéger pour protéger les
autres parce que c'est vraiment le
message clé et malgré tout dans le
contact au quotidien on voit combien
c'est pas tout le temps naturel et on a
toujours cette tentation de serrer la
main et parfois et parfois ça se passe
ça se passe encore
je pense vraiment que c'est c'est la
priorité c'est ce comportement de
responsabilité individuelle dans la vie
quotidienne
maintenant sur les questions virée qui
sont de notre ressort régaliennes et
d'organisation s'agissant des
manifestations il ya un arrêté du
ministre de la santé vous connaissez qui
a été pris qui est interdite sur tout le
territoire national les rassemblements
de plus de cinq mille personnes en
milieu confiné
il ya des questionnements sur les
territoires il y en a sur le territoire
de belfort pour des manifestations qui
sont pas de cette nature soit qu'elles
soient plus petit en milieu confiné soit
qu'elles soient en milieu ouvert et
c'est d'ailleurs déjà dans la presse je
vois mais le carnaval de belfort
typiquement a suscité des interrogations
des organisateurs donc la mairie le
comité des fêtes on en a échangé et
pense préférable ne pas le tenir cette
année
donc une ville ne sera pas tenue par les
organisateurs aux sept années sans que
j'aie besoin ou demande de prendre une
quelconque l'usure simplement on en a
discuté
elle voulait aussi bien appuyé sur la
question des personnes âgées des
structures collectives effectivement les
établissements qui accueillent des
personnes âgées parfois dépendantes et
les mesures particulières qui sont ils
sont à prendre il ya des instructions en
ce sens il ya du bon sens limiter les
contacts et des mesures qui sont prises
par les structures notamment sur les
mesures d'hygiène voulais simplement
dire de façon très concrète que nous y
veillons typiquement aujourd'hui nous
irons visiter deux voire trois
établissements pour nous assurer que les
instructions sont suivis et que ce n'est
pas simplement des documents qu'on a
distribués qui a des suites effectif
c'est à dire que le matériel est
disponible pour se laver les mains que
c'est effectivement fait que ces
systématiques à l'entrée en particulier
dans l'établissement pour les personnes
qui effectuent des visites en souhaitant
qu on ne multiplie pas ces visites comme
ça a été comme ça a été rappelée façon
très très concrète aussi vous dire que
par exemple nous avons pris la tâche des
responsables de lieux de culte les
mosquées l'église catholique qui peuvent
être des lieux communs de discuter le
tas mais peut-être impropre en tous les
cas de rassemblement il s'agit
évidemment pas de prendre une quelconque
mesure
il s'agit de sensibiliser tout le monde
et toutes les parties prenantes aux
mesures à prendre et donc pour le culte
musulman le culte juif le culte
catholique ou protestant qui tous sont
présents et bien que les responsables
je dirais rappelle par exemple que si on
se sent pas bien
eh ben on vient pas occulter
non pas la grande prière du vendredi par
exemple que les personnes âgées bon
regard mais peut-être
il faut être il faut être un petit peu
plus d'an est en réalité sans qu'on ait
besoin de demander beaucoup je suis
frappé par le fait que les responsables
du culte
ils sont attentifs et passe le message
depuis la semaine passée mais on en
discute tranquillement par ailleurs
troisième point rapide sur lequel je
voulais simplement revenir mais pour
redire ce que dit ni de l'intérieur les
élections vont se tenir
vous savez c'est bientôt les élections
municipales donc vont se tenir
nous serons absolument prêt à ce que ça
se passe dans de bonnes conditions d
instruction vont nous être prodigués
services de l'état pour faire en sorte
que ça se passe tranquillement et dans
les meilleures conditions pour le coup
c'est quelque chose je pense qu'ils
aient totalement totalement sous
contrôle
mais on mettre en place les dispositifs
adéquates pour que ça se passe bien vous
vous dire c'est peut-être des mesures
d'ordre intérieur mais c'est un type
c'est important pour la continuité de la
vie de la vie collective que chacune de
nos administrations nos préfectures mais
d'autres services de l'état ont mis en
place une actualisation de leur plan de
continuation de l'activité c'est comme
ça qu'on l'appelle
on s'est peut-être des choses qui
paraissent un peu technocratique mais ça
l'est pas tant que ça ça consiste à
identifier dans nos services typiquement
pour moi dans ma préfecture
quelles sont les missions vitales
sensibles sur lesquels quoi qu'il se
passe je dois être en capacité de
fonctionner et donc je dois être
toujours en mesure d'activer mon centre
opérationnel départemental qui assure la
coordination de la gestion de crise est
bien évidente ça je peux absolument pas
à aucun moment je peux être défaillant
là dessus je dois être en mesure y
compris d'assurer de la communication
grand public
je dois être en mesure de faire des
réquisitions si nécessaire doit être en
mesure de coordonner les questions
d'ordre public et donc tout simplement
on identifie les personnels par vacation
qui par roulement devront être
opérationnels pour maintenir
ces activités de service public
quitte à se protéger et à rester chez
soi si c'était nécessaire
c'est pour vous dire qu'on est dans
l'anticipation et qu'on est prêt qu'on
est on est on est on est vraiment c'est
le sujet sur lequel on fait des points
matin midi et soir effet sur lequel on
est on est pleinement mobilisée et
ensuite on le disait le préfet du doubs
mais en paraît important de de l'appuyer
d'y revenir
la situation économique et les
situations individuelles au plan
économique il est assez clair que les
acteurs du tourisme de l'événementiel
sont là aujourd'hui les plus impactés
par par la situation
voilà donc on hervé y le ministère de
l'économie à d'ores et déjà prévu un
accompagnement si nécessaire au cas par
cas des acteurs économiques avec de
l'activité partielle de l'étalement de
charges fiscales et sociales
là aussi on est dans l'anticipation la
veille mais on se tient prêt s'il y
avait besoin
voilà ce que je voulais dire à ce stade
et des merci monsieur le préfet je pense
que c'était important qu'on fasse ce
tour d'horizon assez large qui vous
permet de voir à quel point c'est une
chaîne complète et ça a été dit ou pas
la peine d'y revenir vous le savez à
quel point toutes les administrations
sont activés actuellement en mode crise
avec des points quotidien avoir
pluriquotidiens pour justement ajuster
les différentes réponses à une situation
qui est très mouvante de jour en jour
maintenant je ne vais là la parole est à
vous
les ai pas alors pour l'instant ils sont
effectivement très limité on vous dira
pas où ça c'est clair ça vous le savez
puisque vous le savez le département oui
c'est dans le doubs mais on ne dira pas
précisément où et c'est une dizaine de
personnes aujourd'hui en ehpad qui ont
été contrefaits qui ont été dépistés
dépistées positives à son tour remonte
quasiment 10 heures hier puisque je
rappelle qu'il y avait pas de cas dans
la partie franc-comtoise mardi dans le
même établissement à l'identifier le
foyer infectieux mulhouse
oui je pourrais me dire combien j'ai une
autre question vous parlais justement de
la mobilisation du personnel vous
convient de rappeler éventuellement des
personnels retraités pour justement
renforcer cette mobilisation alors sur
sur les chiffres
alors qu'ils vont les chiffres d'hier
soir sont pas les chiffres d'aujourd'hui
puisque vous savez la situation est
risible utile moi je vais vous donner
pour le chu de besançon et dernier
chiffre que moi j'ai en ma possession
qui seront certainement donc enfin qui
seront repris ce soir
mais voilà
cette nuit on a eu six nouveaux cas donc
pour le chu de besançon
nous en sommes en total de 19 on a eu un
cas mercredi 12 cas jeudi 6 qui ont été
dépistés hier soi et on a eu les
résultats de cette nuit donc on a 19
sur ces 19 nous avons neuf soignants du
chu de besançon
une personne qui est hospitalisé et 8
qui sont contre à domicile sur les
nombres d'hospitaliser ou au jour
d'aujourd'hui à l'heure où je vous parle
nous avons six hospitalisés passion dont
un en réanimation et 13 donc ils sont
partis en fait ils sont en ambulatoire
voilà la cie gestion à la prive pas oui
alors nous avons commencé c'est à dire
que nous avons pris les listings des
retraités partis en 2019 et on les a
appelés hier après midi pour voir
éventuellement et on n'a pas eu beaucoup
beaucoup de résultats positifs donc
aujourd'hui on va prendre aldis de 2018
faut essayer de voir si des personnes
peuvent se mobiliser mais ça rejoint ce
que ce qu'évoquait le seul préfet juste
avant c'est à dire que à partir du
moment où on est en anticipation
mais de fait tous les établissements
sont en train d'activer d'une façon
d'autres leur pca dans le jargon c'est
la plan de continuation d'activité qui
là encore n'est pas une vraie une percée
conceptuel liés aux kovy 19 je rappelle
que ce soit le strass en 2003 h1n1 en
2009 à chaque fois on a eu des plans de
continuation d'activité qui ont été
faits avec différents stades
de dégradation de la possibilité de la
réponse des services publics votre
question oui monsieur
interrogé si vous dégager des places de
parking officiel besançon l'heure était
grave
m kim est on des cache pas on a des
urgences qui se disent depuis depuis des
mois la crise de nerfs at on vraiment
les capacités de faire face à une crise
d'ampleur
oui oui parce que les choses s organisé
justement les anticiper oui on est en
capacité la preuve regardez on est
capable en espace d'une semaine de
prendre de plus de 200 appels
supplémentaires par rapport à ce qu'on a
l'habitude au quotidien donc sans agent
capable de faire on est capable alors qu
on a quinze postes de passer à 33 postes
en l'espace de quelques jours
donc on est capable de s'organiser on
est capable d'ouvrir un centre d'accueil
avec cinq six boxes supplémentaires on
est capable de faire ça dans les huit
jours donc oui on est capable de prendre
en charge la situation
et oui nous avons le personnel qui est
mobilisé et sachez aussi que quand on
est dans des situations un petit peu
grave
le personnel se mobilise oui je vais le
couple était un tout petit peu cette
réponse effectivement extrêmement
important de et vous l'avez observé à
chaque fois quand on a des situations de
crise dans le monde sanitaire
il ya une immense solidarité
véritablement les personnels se mobilise
tout le monde est sur le pont
spontanément éventuellement même les
gens congi rappel pour savoir s'il faut
qu'il vienne travailler
donc je pense que ce qui est c'est la
souplesse et la richesse de ce système
hospitalier ce qui ne veut pas dire que
par ailleurs on n'a pas en continu des
difficultés organisationnelles le
structurel qu'il faut traiter par
ailleurs mais je pense qu'il faut pas
les 20 il faut clairement distinguer les
deux c'est à dire via les situations
exceptionnelles pour lesquels tout le
monde se mobilise et au détriment et
vous l'avez entendu éventuellement
d'autres activités ce qu'a expliqué la
directrice générale du chu en
déprogrammant certaines activités parce
qu'on focalise sur le problème à traiter
et l'armée les moyens nécessaires en
revanche sassine ça veut pas dire qu'on
peut travailler comme ça pendant des
mois et des mois puisque les personnels
de fait sont soumis à une importante
les répressions avec un nombre d'heures
supplémentaires qui explose avec
évidemment eu un accompagnement ensuite
statutaire qu'il faut accompagner pour
les personnels qui sont mobilisés c'est
vrai aussi au niveau de l'administration
savez c'est assez rare l'administration
fonctionne 24 heures sur 24 avec des
hotlines ouverte 24 ce qui est le cas
aujourd'hui de la ligne du numéro vert
national
et justement si on se projette sur un
éventuellement il passe trois comment ça
va se passer c'est déjà tendues entre
chargé
paradoxalement les enjeux sont
complètement différent dans la phase iii
puisque je le répète la phase 1 c'est
vraiment confiné au maximum pour que le
virus ne rentre pas la phase ii s'est
confiné encore au maximum pour éviter la
diffusion et à partir du moment où on a
ce qu'on appelle des clusters c'est à
dire des zones de contamination autonome
ou sur certains territoires comme vous
savez il y en a dans le morbihan dans
l'oise dans la hotte de la savoie
actuellement haute-savoie d'ailleurs
comment donc sa voix on a à ce moment là
une autre stratégie qui est de limiter
les conséquences de l'épidémie c'est à
dire de toujours évidemment confiner les
patients mais à partir de là ce sont
mesures barrières j'y reviens et civisme
c'est à dire encore une fois c'est ce 15
août où nous avons tous rappelés dont je
ne répète pas
c'est la façon de limiter les contacts
partir du moment où il ya une seule
technologie donc paradoxalement la
pression sur le système de santé peut
aussi diminuer en phase iii
paradoxalement puisque les patients vont
beaucoup plus être à domicile suivi à
domicile avec l'entrée en lice de façon
importante de toute la médecine
ambulatoire sur le suivi à domicile des
patients
donc on est on est dans une autre une
autre dynamique et puis il faut rester
optimiste c'est à dire les personnels
les personnels qui aujourd'hui sont chez
eux
vous savez dans huit des douze jours en
tout cas 80 jours ma joie ils vont
revenir
donc on alors vous allez me dire il y en
a d'autres qui vont peut-être tomber
malawi mais il y en a quand même qui
vont revenir on est dans un système où
finalement le confinement ses quatorze
jours après les personnels vont bien
travaillé
non alors vous faites très bien poser la
question puisque nous avons un lien
étroit évidemment avec les recteurs et
notamment le recteur inclina
interacadémiques de besançon et il n'y a
aucune ne nous ne sommes pas dans des
zones de clusters n'y a aucune éviction
scolaire dans l'académie de
franche-comté ni d'ailleurs dans
l'académie de dijon ni aucune fermeture
d'établissements scolaires attendre dans
la rentrée lundi
[Musique]
à l'heure où je vous parle ce sera
peut-être 30 cet après-midi quand on
publiera le confirme le communiqué de
presse alors là vous savez les meilleurs
statisticiens épidémiologistes de france
paralysant nuit sur le sujet pour
essayer de modéliser donc je nous
n'avons pas ce jour la réponse à la
question aux sapeurs pompiers de la
région qu'est ce qui a changé au niveau
de leurs interventions
ce qui a changé au niveau de leurs
interventions pour l'instant je dirais
rien puisque encore une fois comme ça a
été rappelé par le docteur blasphème le
centre 15
réguler la totalité des transports
nécessaires et les transporteurs qui
acheminent les patients de toute façon
soit c'est le smur soit ça peut être
potentiellement les 10 soit ça peut être
les transporteurs privés les
ambulanciers sont à ce moment-là équipés
ont l'équipement de protection
nécessaires pour acheminer les patients
en sécurité vers le chu où un autre
hôpital selon les cas puisque je vous
dis maintenant depuis cette semaine il
n'y a plus que les il n'y a pas que les
deux chu tous les établissements de
première et deuxième ligne donc les dix
établissements de la région sont
susceptibles d'être mobilisées pour
accueillir des patients
sur la justice ça se passe comment en
fait il ya un suivi une personne qui
passe tous les jours où un suivi
téléphonique alors je laisserai le chu
complété pour aller les siens entre 10
mai pour seul que l'on ce que l'on
connaît en général les modalités s'est
définie par chaque site ça chante le
principe est celui d'un contact
quotidien avec le patient c'est tout
puisque encore une fois si vous avez de
la fièvre et que vous avez
éventuellement même tout sans gravité il
n'y a pas nécessité de passage d'une
équipe d'un soignant ou quoi que ce soit
mais il ya un contact est par exemple je
vous cite l'exemple de dijon mais le
besançon complétera le chu suisse et les
patients à domicile avec le relais de
l'achat des en cas de besoin c'est à
dire s'il ya nécessité
c'est une infirmière de l'achat dès
qu'ils seront prêts du patient avec le
support du service d'infectiologie si
encore une fois en cas de besoin ces
patients sont pas c'est pas systématique
et on espère bien que les gens vous de
14 jours on leur dit vous êtes guéri
terminé précisions supplémentaires par
jour au centre 15 il y en a combien
habitude à peu près à peu près un petit
peu plus de 1000 par jour
oui oui à peu près mille îles
oui
oui ça sent les parents oui c'est ça un
parking à l'entrée à l'hôpital ça passe
pour les gens concrètement le braconnage
eux alors il n'ya pas comment dire des
places dédiées il ya un parcours c'est à
dire que vous allez arriver devant
l'entrée des urgences pas d urgence
devant l'entrée de l'hôpital
vous allez dire pourquoi vous rencontrer
et on va vous dire de suivre un chemin
particulier c'est à dire au lieu de
partir sur les urgences
vous allez partir sur votre gauche mais
c'est juste derrière des panneaux qui
vont vous permettre de vous mettre sur
un parking
là vous appelez et on vient vous
chercher voilà un homme non non non
jamais spontanément centre 15 en
téléphone d'abord on va pas bien c'est
le sait le centre qu'aucun c'est
vraiment ça faut surtout pas que les
gens il arrive comme ça à n'importe
comment etc
ces centres 15 on a du monde pour
répondre au téléphone à tous les tous
les appels oui oui ce serait une bonne
chose pour l'instant pas encore non elle
peut fonctionner mais on est en train
pour votre information au niveau de l'
agence pas plus tard qu'aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs de regarder comment la plate
forme de télémédecine qui existent au
niveau de la région bourgogne franche
comté comme vous savez la plateforme
tellme ne pourrait activer très
rapidement
avec notamment les médecins traitants
toujours ça surtout de l'intérêt pour et
le 15 éventuellement pour certains
patients et surtout en phase 3 lorsqu'on
aura potentiellement c'est pas
fatalement fin on s'y attend à voir
beaucoup de patients à domicile à suivre
à domicile et toutes nous nous y
réfléchissons puisqu'on a déjà la base
technique dans la région pour le faire
avec la plate forme de télémédecine mais
encore faut-il que les professionnels se
branchent dessus mais ça ils ont un
accès ouvert mais aussi que
potentiellement les patients puissent se
brancher dessus si on veut faire de la
téléconsultation et ça c'est
techniquement possible et sa demande
ça demande un peu de temps ça dans
quelques semaines mais on y travaille
d'ores et déjà une personne avait une
wii des tutsis d'âge
alors pour l'instant dans la littérature
les séries c'est des séries de milliers
de malades chinoise ou coréennes ou
autres commencent à être publiés qui
sont publiés depuis le début de l'année
pensez bien que sur 18 19 cas donner des
statistiques ou de ça ça n'a pas de sens
ce qu'on sait sur les séries chinoises
coréennes qui commencent à arriver dans
la littérature c'est qu'ils ont général
en moyenne une soixantaine d'années
environ
ces gens là vont faire une forme plus
grave c'est à dire qu'en fait ils vont
avoir quoi s'est il respire se sentent
pas bien il ne respire pas bien et ils
ont besoin d'un petit peu d'oxygène
d'accord donc là on ne peut pas avoir
ces à domicile donc là ils sont
hospitalisés
81 10 fois sur 100 90 92
ça se passe très bien en quelques jours
sa cèdent ils vont pouvoir sortir
tranquillement dans 5 10 10 % des cas à
peu près les choses s'aggravent le
besoin en oxygène sa g
on a besoin de plus 2 litres d'oxygène
pour maintenir les paramètres du taux et
à ce moment là c'est un transfert il
faut des soins plus lourds plus
complexes d assistance éventuellement
respiratoires et là c'est dans le
secteur de réanimation
voilà un petit peu le pas ce que je peux
vous dire un petit peu brève
présentation générale
oui bien sûr oui pour l'instant là ce
qu'on a comme ce qui remonte de un petit
peu de l'expérience des centres français
et des réanimateurs notamment et des
infectiologues
c'est ça colle tout à fait à ça et on
est très surpris
il permet d'insister par le ça peut être
quelque chose de rassurant car à
l'instar du faible cas de pédiatrie
concernés ça il faut le dire aussi
peut-être
je ne peux pas vous dire je suis pas un
expert virologue autres mais tout le
monde se pose la question en tout cas ce
qu'il ressort de la plupart des séries
actuellement est prononcée d'en avoir
c'est le les faibles car pédiatrique
vraiment ils sont très très peu touché
les enfants ne me demandez pas pourquoi
nous ne savons pas c'est tant mieux
d'ailleurs c'est plutôt rassurant truies
c'est des messages plutôt rassurant pour
les parents
et comme le disait tout le monde c'est
nos aînés
les formes graves ou les décès qui a en
france vous avez vu les âges des
patients vous comprenez bien que à ces
âges là où au très bien forcément il ya
des ce qu'on appelle nous des
comorbidités et que voilà c'est déjà
beaucoup plus fragile d'où vraiment le
message qui revient protégeons nos gens
les plus fragiles
oui c'est vraiment ça c'est à dire que
en termes de comportement citoyen vous
voyez bien le message que je complète
donc nous sommes dans la logique de ne
pas être dans une inquiétude trop
technique ne faut pas être dans la
légèreté ce qui vient d'être dit là
c'est important cela veut dire que
chaque citoyen doit modifier ses
comportements en particulier par rapport
à la protection des personnes âgées des
transports en commun ou nettoyage des
corps
chose particulière bon sens des mesures
particulières n'ont en revanche pour les
établissements de santé aux
établissements médico-sociaux
effectivement ils ont reçu un rappel
encore une fois c'est un rappel des
consignes en matière de d'hygiène des
locaux en matière de désinfection des
surfaces mais il n'y a encore une fois
rien d'original c'est plus un rappel des
bonnes pratiques qui devrait être celle
du quotidien à commencer par le lavage
des mains qui est normalement de règle
dans les établissements de santé et
médico-sociaux avant de passer de d'un
malade ou d'un résident à un autre et
c'est le désinfection des mains de vrais
systématique tous les patients tous les
jours donc c'est une occasion aussi pour
les équipes opérationnelles d'hygiène de
tous les établissements de santé de la
région de rappeler ces pratiques de base
qui sont faites de l'hygiène collective
vasic donc ça a été rappelé en effet
pour répondre à votre question les
établissements ont reçu tous les
établissements de touche médico social
et ainsi que des établissements
sanitaires leur a rappelé l'équipe
opérationnelle d'hygiène telles celles
de dani mais aussi par monsieur gbagbo
ont rappelé aux établissements et aux
personnels dans son dos et me suis senti
très claire 44 vous disais dans la
région et en comptant les nouveaux car à
vos enfants d'hier à ses heures oui ah
d'accord donc là le nouveau le rouage ou
pearl dans la région nous sommes plutôt
à 70 d'accord ok et dans les 19 à
besançon vous comptez les personnes de
l'ebad aussi non non non un moment moi
je parle chien qui concerne je parle
des chiffres qu'on a eu cette nuit et
qui concerne danse d'être assuré
du personnel de l'hôpital qui a été donc
cas positifs cette nuit donc cessé pour
le chu de besançon
c'est un + 12 et ce soit la chance à
vous dire plus plus six mais je vous le
dis tout de suite puisque je le sais moi
aujourd'hui mais ce soir ça sera plus 6
par rapport à hier
et c'est ce que va vous dire la chance
sachant que peut-être que ce soir ça
sera même plus le bon chiffre de fortune
disque on va dire ma chance quant aux
risques que ça soit pas de gros chiffres
donc ça sera plus ça sera plus mais ça
ni la chance ni moi ne le savons il ne
le seront que dans la nuit au moins deux
fois par deux fois par jour nous avons
donc des tests qui sont réalisés mais si
vous laissez pas un tube par un tube
c'est pas un prélèvement par un
prélèvement ccd chaîne et donc il ya
deux séries une le matin une soir ce qui
vous permet de comprendre d'ailleurs que
les chiffres sont plus tellement le
problème aujourd'hui puisque où il est
entré dans une phase épidémique ou
l'important évidemment nous nous suivons
les cas mais vous voyez bien que entre
les ces deux séries de laboratoire qui
sortent à dijon et à besançon tous les
jours nous arrêtons les compteurs à la
rs en début d'après-midi au gnr 15h sur
les premières séries du matin tous les
jours ce qui fait le communiqué de
presse qui vous est diffusée à tous vers
16h désormais ce qui permet au national
à 19h au professeur salomon directeur
général de la santé de faire le point
nationale mais entre temps c'est déjà
devenu faut par définition puisque entre
temps nous avons la série du soir qui
est arrivé que nous commençons à traiter
la cellule de crise
investigue notamment par rapport à l'or
qu'à contacter par donc donc les
chiffres n'ont quasiment pas de plus
vraiment de sens qui importe c'est
l'état des patients le nombre de
patients guéris la façon dont ils sont
maintenant maintenus à domicile et la
façon dont on accompagne notamment
toutes les mesures de prévention
populationnelle pas qu'on a tous insisté
à la fois messieurs les préfets le chu
tout le monde moi même le on est entré
dans une phase ii où le civisme est
important de civisme c'est à dire être
conscient que chacun peut être vecteur
et contaminer son entourage le moment
donné et notamment gevrey dit toujours
on n'embrasse pas sa grand-mère quand on
touche à l'heure où alors non je vous
alors que vous évoquez vous évoquez je
suppose
l'événement d'un bus qui sera arrivé à
contrarier le personnes en provenance de
mulhouse c'est ça que vous évoquez bon
tout ça rentre dans les les éléments que
vous a présenté le directeur général de
l'air est ce vous avez compris quel
événement particulier qui a touché notre
notre région qui est l'événement de
mulhouse évoqué les conséquences
sanitaires qui vous ont été décrites
c'est un club qu'il faut le comprendre
je pense qu'on vous n'arriverez pas à
toi c'est parce qu'elle demande et je
crois les autorités sanitaires à faire
une cartographie commune par commune de
la situation sanitaire
le panel de pandala monde est un
évènement important c'est
qu'effectivement l'événement 2
cultuel de mulhouse donc a eu un impact
significatif sur la situation sanitaire
dans notre région en particulier dans le
département du doubs mais on leur
franche comté également wii est
clairement puisque presque à ce jour
parce que la moitié des cas que nous
avons eu à déplorer dans l'art dans la
région notamment la partie franc
comtoise de la région sont liées cet
événement et combien vous pratiquez de
tests par jour avec le pourcentage des
briques et ça je ne peux pas répondre à
votre question puisque moi je n'ai qui
est positif alors globalement dans le
laboratoire p3 du chu de besançon
on arrive et deux tournées donc c'est
les techniques de re2 qu'on appelle de
rt pcr qui sont des points qui
nécessitent un marquage 10 juillet assez
lourde
ça nécessite du temps bien sûr une
mobilisation des équipes là
globalement on est monté en puissance là
aussi il ya une quarantaine
quarantaine minimum hier on en a fait
sens
voilà donc j'étais à 40 x 2 les lacets
58 à 2 sur le chu ça revient aux
chiffres vous adonner à peu près c'est à
dire le ratio à peu près entre les
séquelles compliqué un cas quels
chiffres on prend par rapport à fin juin
mais ça n'a pas beaucoup de soin de
l'argent sachant je voyais le scander
visée c'est celle où l'on réalise les
tests sont réalisés et les passions
comme je le dit son nom du classique de
nos charges
on évoquait qui devait être activée dans
certaines zones de france qu'il pouvait
avoir les discussions qu'elle souhaitait
dans certaines zones de france
ce que la bourgogne franche comté à
cette affection pas encore on en est pas
rendu à ce stade là on est pas on n'est
pas à ce stade là en bourgogne franche
comté puisque la définition d'un cluster
c'est véritablement la transmission dans
une zone géographique d'un foyer
autonome auto portée de transmission
comme ça existait dans l'oise commence à
exister en bretagne autour de carnac
on n'a pas de foyer comme ça nous on a
une certaine façon je n'ose pas dire par
chance mes nono cas groupés sont des cas
qui sont chesnais épidémiologiquement
c'est à dire on sait que c'est on a une
dizaine de cas qui ont été freinés à
l'oise parce que des gens étaient allés
dans lois sont revenus en côte-d'or et
cjad le groupe
la dizaine de patients de côte-d'or
conte et de la semaine dernière sont
liés à la chaîne de transmission de
l'oise mais sont bien liés c'est à dire
qu'on a le patient index qui est qui a
contaminé d'autres et dont on sait
tracer précisément qui a contaminé qui
dans la chaîne
idem pour mulhouse c'est un peu plus
compliqué pour mulhouse parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup de gens et on voit
maintenant ils émergent des émerge
progressivement dans la région en même
temps à 14 jours de l'événement de
mulhouse on va être tranquille quand
même hein donc il faut aussi croiser les
doigts
alors ça n'empêchera pas qui
éventuellement des chaînes de
transmission secondaire qui puisse
exister mais l'intérêt aussi d'avoir un
événement initial index il sait que plus
on s'éloigne de l'événement pullulent
mais en même temps faut pas être trop
rassurant non plus puisque ça veut dire
que des gens qui est éventuellement
asymptomatiques ou très peu
symptomatiques ont pu contaminer
d'autres dans leur entourage
mais à ce stade on aime 10 et enfin on a
une réflexion pour votre information
tous les soirs avec le ministère de la
santé avec le directeur général de la
santé sur justement pour les 18 régions
13 métropolitaine plus les outre-mer la
façon dont on discute
kloster pas kloster d'une part et
éventuellement qui en est déjà à un
stade iii ou pas ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui de toute façon bhl je le
redis la doctrine nationale toute la
france est en stade deux façons les
personnes en stade 3 au constat d'un
tout le monde est en stade 2 sur un plan
des mesures